القبه الحديديه تسميه دعائيه توحي بان
سماء اسرائيل محصنه محميه لا شيء يخترقها
مثلا فيجلس الاسرائيلي في الشارع يمسك
الارجيله وينظر الى السماء يتفرج على عرض
الالعاب الناريه في سماء بلاده
قالوا ان نسبه فاعليتها 90% يعني اذا كان
هناك 100 صاروخ ستصد تسعين منهم لكن منذ
دخول نظام الاعتراض الخدمه في اسرائيل في
عام 2011 لوحظا انخفاضا في قدراتها على صد
الصواريخ
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول في هذه الجوله من
القصف ان خمسه او 500 وسبعه صواريخ اطلقت
من قطاع غزه
368 منها اجتازت حدود اسرائيل اين الحمايه
تسعين في المئه اذا كان 72% منها سقطت
داخل اسرائيل هم يقولون نحن لا نحسب
القذائف التي ستسقط في مناطق غير ماهوله
فلا تتفاعل القبه ولا صافرات انذار عندها
ثم ان اعتراض كل صاروخ دفاعي يكلف بين 50
و 100 الف دولار بينما كلفه صاروخ
المقاومه قصير المدى بين 300 الى 800
دولار امريكي لكل صاروخ ما الاسباب التي
خفضت من فعاليه القبه الحديديه اولا
تطور صواريخ الفصائل وغزاره اطلاقها
الحيل ايضا التي تستخدمها المقاومه باطلاق
صواريخ فارغه صواريخ فارغه المحتوى باقل
كلفه ممكنه وتلك التي تفعل القبه الحديديه
تزيد الثقل عليها ليتم بعدها اطلاق قرشقات
صاروخيه تخترق القبه وقد وصلت الرشقات
الصاروخيه الى سماء تل ابيب اي في العمق
الاسرائيلي
تعترضها القبه الحديديه هناك شاهدوا
الرجاله
ما رايتموه في هذا الفيديو دفع اسرائيل
للتفكير بالاستعانه بمكون جديد من
منظوماتها الدفاعيه ساوضحها هنا القبه
الحديديه تعرفونها هي مخصصه فقط لاعتراض
صواريخ قصيره المدى قصيره يعني قصيره مدى
الى سبعين كيلو متر فقط
بعدها هناك نظام دفاعي اخر اسمه مقلاع
داوود هذه
المنظومه تتكفل بتغطيه تهديدات الصواريخ
متوسطه المدى يعني 150 كيلومترا من 70 الى
150 اما التي اتصل
صواريخ بعيده المدى فهي السهم اثنان
وثلاثه تلك
مخصصه للصواريخ الباليستيه بعيده المدى
نستعرض لكم بعضا من التغريدات التي توضح
طبيعه النقاش الدائر بين الاسرائيليين عن
فعاليات قبتهم الحديديه ايتان ايتان قالت
في التغريده قدره القبه الحديديه اصبحت
لعنه اصبحنا نسمع للعدو بامتلاك سلاح
بينما يزداد عدد الناس في الملاجئ ويزداد
ضحايا القلق وتزداد عدد صواريخ ومداها في
كل جوله ويبدو الامر وكانه مدام ليس هناك
اصابات فالقبه ناجحه هذا عار علينا اما
بالنسبه لاييل شوشاني ايال قال لك الوضع
يتحسن من حيث الخسائر من جانبنا مقابل
الخسائر في صفوفهم يتم تطوير القبه
الحديديه وانا ما سياتي نظام الليزر حينها
لن ينجح اي استثمار لحماس في الصواريخ
شماجي شماجي يقول لك القبه الحديديه تضر
اكثر مما تنفع وبدلا من تسويه غزه بالارض
فانهم يحسبون عدد او يحسبون عدد عمليات
الاعتراض منددي ريزل يقول لك خلال ساعه
انفجر صاروخ خامس في نفس المنطقه في مجلس
اشكول الاقليمي
سبب اضرار سبب اضرارا جسيمه ولم تقع
اصابات مرحبا ايتها القبه الحديديه هل انت
معنا
جاكو اخر تغريده في هذه القصه يقول لك في
عام 2006 لم يكن لدينا قبه حديديه ودخلنا
حرب لبنان وعانينا ثم بعدها ساد السلام في
غزه علينا حتى يسودا السلام والان لدينا
قبه حديديه سنعاني اقل ولكن لين هياها لا
يمكننا ان نعيش من جوله قتال لاخرى
كشف تحقيق لسلاح الجو الاسرائيلي عن وجود
خلل فنيا في منظومه القبه في تفعيل هذه
المنظومه في حال
عدم اعتراض الصواريخ التي اطلقت من غزه
على
الاختبار الحقيقي الذي تواجهه هذه القبه
هو اثناء توجيه وابل من الصواريخ رجقات
صاروخيه في دفعه واحده تسمح لبعضها
باختراق القبه وارباكها فلا تستطيع
التغطيه بشكل فعال ولا بكثافه الصواريخ
الهاطله من السماء